[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday April
12th no matter where I am and even if I
have no clear idea where I am and no
matter how much trouble I may be in I
can achieve a blank and shining serenity
if only I can reach the very edge of a
natural body of water the very edge of
anything from a rivulet to an ocean says
to me now you know where you are now you
know which way to go
you will soon be home now that is
because I made my first mental maps of
the world in the summer time when I was
a little child on the shores of Lake
Maxinkuckee which is in northern Indiana
Maxinkuckee is three miles long and two
and a half miles across at its widest it
Shores are a closed loop no matter where
I was on its circumference all I had to
do was keep walking in one direction to
find my way home again what a confident
Marco Polo I could be when setting out
for a day's adventure yes and I asked
the reader of this piece my
indispensable collaborator isn't your
deepest understanding of time and space
and for that matter destiny shaped like
mine by your earliest experiences with
geography by the rules you learned about
how to get home again the closed loop of
the lakeshore was certain to bring me
home not only to my own family's
unheated frame cottage on a bluff
overlooking the lake but to for adjacent
cottages teaming with close relatives
the heads of those neighboring
households moreover my father's
generation had also spent their
childhood summer times at Maxinkuckee
making them the almost immediate
successors there to the Potawatomi
Indians they even had a tribal name for
themselves which sounded like pepti
Mayan hoist sometimes my father when a
grown man would call out to Maxinkuckee
in general abdomen hoy and a first
cousin fishing from a leaky rowboat or a
sister reading in a hammock or whatever
would give this reply yah at to Mayan
hey what did it mean it was pure
nonsense from their childhood it was
German meaning this due habits mohei yes
Abbot's mo hey so what so not very much
I guess except that it allows me to say
that after the Potter with Tommy's came
the up to my invoice who have vanished
from Lake Maxinkuckee without a trace it
is though they had
never been there am i sad not at all
because everything about that lake was
imprinted on my mind when it held so
little information and with so eager for
information it will be my lake as long
as I live I have no wish to visit it for
I have kept it all right here I happen
to see it last spring from about six
miles up on a flight from Louisville to
Chicago it was as emotionally uninvolved
rye dust viewed from under a microscope
again that wasn't the real Maxinkuckee
down there the real one is in my head
we'll miss you I'll see you tomorrow